so what do you think of a new foot I
think I can get in less trouble around
from Mischa Barton is returning to TV
you have no idea
et has learned the 32 year old OC star
is joining at the hills reboot really
you are though the actress never
appeared in the original MTV series she
does have a small connection to the show
The OC helped inspire MTV's Laguna Beach
which later spun off into the hills
starring Lauren Conrad Elsie is not
returning for the reboot but cast
members like Heidi Montag and even
Justin Bobby are this isn't misha's
first time on reality TV she competed on
Dancing with the Stars in 2016 I'm
seeing real big shifts in who you are as
a person if you'll remember she exited
the OCE
early in 2006 when I did the OSI I think
I just got to the point where I was like
I'm not sure I'm enjoying this anymore
so it was time to like step back so I
went back to England and it was just a
year of real self exploration
since then Mischa has experienced some
personal troubles including a 2007 DUI
arrest and hospitalizations in 2009 and
again in 2017 I think it was complete
hallucination I have no idea what I was
talking about yeah the hills new
beginnings is slated to premiere on MTV
in 2019
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]